to welcome one and all to the first and
last place for all the news weekly
gaffes and happenings of every week if
you're interested and laughs news viral
hits and smashes all you need to do is
come right here to the h3 podcast every
Tuesday and Friday to get your fill back
me up on that ela I love the smashes the
smashes everything you need baby we got
it all here today first of all let me
thank our sponsors Noom and me undies
we've got a heck of a show here today
heck of a show featuring we've been
putting together resumes applications
PowerPoint presentations of girls that
want to be mrs. Slater this is the
intern mrs. the intern dan are we
working on getting in and intern because
I definitely want to get in the interns
intern whoa here I think that would be a
good addition to the shell sure right
you know I mean that's funny that's a
good gag yeah mrs. the intern so I'm
very excited we have a lot of really
good applications we're gonna get in in
here and he's gonna hand out roses to
his final contestants so we're gonna
have to how is it gonna hand the roads
where does it go I'll hand it to me the
metaphorical you know you make look good
but before that guys I promised you hits
and gaps so let's start from the top
what's poppin on twitter baby it's all
about the fish cannon you know what I'm
saying apparently and I still somehow
think this is fake it's not so this is
uh to help fish pass over dams in
seconds rather than days now I don't
know why they're in such a hurry to get
the fish into the other side what's the
big deal of a couple day detour see I'm
very skeptical of this that this is like
such a procedure and then it sucks them
in
at such a high velocity and how does it
not damage them to get sucked through
that tube at such a high speed is this
currently like a rendering or that's the
way I think it's fake is because look at
this this is the fake of everything this
is a bananas fish patch system is said
to be a safer and effective way to help
with fish migration like this is a
render that's a render let's watch this
again now homie puts it in a tube and
they get sucked out like both speed this
is a render that looks real but it could
be anything
right oh I feel like I feel like
everyone got bamboozled by this who is
cheddar yeah exactly that's all you need
to know that this is fake and then they
hit the water at like a thousand miles
an hour that's how they go the whoosh
innovations also how do they catch these
fish these wild fish and what is with
these corny renderings if you worked
really hard on such a serious innovation
would you call it whoosh innovation no I
would call it cheddar I don't know what
is I just know they can't make this one
better Photoshop the system can also
call out like what would justify such a
let me read the writing because they're
trying to convince me that this fake
[ __ ] is real but I can't imagine what
could possibly justify such an elaborate
tube helps Nate a fish pass over the dam
in seconds rather than days ok I don't
know what's such the hurry
really amused by you being so bothered
by this because it's fake Bush
innovations like look at how many people
it takes to even do this that's what I
don't know are you really telling me
that there's like 10 people on Angela
shoving fish into this to who is it
gonna pay for this bush innovations
created a fish transport system ok is
this a new season of Nathan for you
right exactly
by the way look how fake this fish's I'm
telling you look at this fish it
move it's a huge fish it doesn't move
why do you put it in upside down
well the tail actually moved in in it I
don't know you tell me
I guess I've x-files music when it puts
in yeah but it got sucked at a trillion
miles a second
soft tubes move fish from water below a
dam to the spawning grounds above okay
but why yeah you better tell me why
right now that's a rendering bad one too
it's also said to have helped in salmon
recovery at a lower cost than fish
ladders what's a fish ladder that sounds
fake also probably just what it sounds
like at this the system can also call
out non-native species that wreak havoc
so they're saying all the fake ass fish
that don't belong here don't get a free
reply nup man and then does not look
violent like how can I survive this look
at the [ __ ] be easier yeah and increases
predation and I didn't get the selective
fish passage system is said to be a
safer and effective way to help with
fish migration I don't know man I don't
buy it I mean do you guys agree there's
something fishy part of my bonnibel I do
not agree I'm gonna have to hard
disagree on this one you think it's real
yeah that's real oh you do yeah I mean I
might regret that when I find out that
I've been totally bamboo well it has 25
million views this clip does anyone back
there have a little spidel Spidey tingly
about that this might be a ruse I feel
like this is like an early April Fool's
joke mm-hmm early early early like they
missed the cutoff no I just I just
googled it there's a this news article
about it it seems to be one papers it in
time time fishing magazine reminds me of
this taken about fish in the tubes fish
in the
because you know these salmon they got a
good upstream man we got the fish tip is
more than a mean there you go
Fox Fox mmm-hmm and everyone's in on it
this conspiracy goes deeper than I
thought anyway that's what's not on
Twitter kill the fish though that's what
I said it's like it's like you're
shooting them out of a gun practically
the two seems a song to me yeah okay
it's no but but the the part that you
pointed out where they slam into the
metal cage yeah I mean it looks like a
fast way to cook home but like right a
lot of friction they come out ready to
eat what do you read why are EULA I'm
trying to find more information why is
it so important so these articles are
these not just online articles that are
trying to get clicks Dan are you talking
about time no no and apparently John
Oliver did a whole segment a few years a
chameleon yeah I just got to that too
yeah so Oliver and I'm not guys not -
there you go time Time magazine Sam and
Ken and everyone's talking about this
has been popular for a minute
the salmon cannon is taking everyone for
a joyride
all right here we go let's see if this
looks real this is a real time can yeah
okay that's from cheddar as well we've
already proved disproving these guys as
on credible sources you tell me cheddar
is not what it look how she put the rat
in like hatefully watch this girl she's
like get the [ __ ] out of my river right
so II like here's them you know there's
someone I listening who knows the
answers to everything and they're like
yeah yelling at the screen there is a
dustless salmon biologist who is [ __ ]
pissed right now the show well this one
is shows a little more context that
other ones showing these really corny
renderings so it's they're here EULA
look well my Fit what I've learned I'm
just trying to find why look how fast
they hit the water dude
watch this like a torpedo boom he's out
of there though alright yeah he's fine
alright well you know I don't know it's
a little strange it's definitely strange
but ela well how do you explain this
woman hatefully throwing the fish in
there look at her get the [ __ ] out of my
River it's like she wants it to die well
look at her she's scornfully if it needs
to go with momentum you know the whoosh
I all right let's get out there I mean I
think I've proved disproved this I think
this is proven we could put the stamp on
it proven fake sure so that's what's
poppin total world
next up we've got some fan submissions
we've been talking about how cuter
people are still breezy after all these
years and fans submitted guys remember
if you want to submit podcast at h3h3
productions calm so we've got some more
mobility scooter crazy people this one
comes from Alex mute audio a note to
myself because guess what okay I got it
because guess what YouTube is totally
insane here we go I do really honestly
think that 90% of all people that ride
scooters are totally Bracy like who like
look at this guy's attempting to go up
an escalator in a scooter any [ __ ] and I
mean well I'm not quite sure what the
expected outcome they you know dislike
this they think the scooter solves at
all yeah it's just like a I can't walk
they gave me this scooter this is my
yeah you know it's funny don't worry the
lady was okay thank you anima sucker now
what's funny is this person who slams
the emergency brake was kind of
unhelpful because now she's just
stranded in the middle of the escalator
I mean I better at least just
often yeah right now you're just stuck
in the middle of nowhere that's true
yeah so scooter people are still brazii
I love this like no hesitation like
she's even going to hold the thing no
hesitation you know and then whoops see
ya mm-hmm once you see it on a scooter
all logic just gets lost everything you
know about the word is out what was she
thinking the scooter got to her brain
man
so there you go scooter people I think
we need some applications from people
with no normal scooter people who
wouldn't do such crazy thing they don't
exist
mm-hmm what do you want to swatch videos
of people just responsibly riding around
in scooters sounds boring this once was
submitted by Nathan M let's see oh yeah
scooter people are still Bracy ela watch
this [ __ ] this is a viral hit this video
he's blocking our cart shirtless
yeah you fullscreen our wait hold on
hold on back it up back it up way she's
beating the hell out of her own car
scooter people are braised in salad
Rollie pollie by the way that is fine
just look at him he's fine you know get
like fat and they're just like I can't
walk anymore that dude come on he's fine
but again get in the mind of him I'm
blocking this woman's car I mean be
happy should I run you over the scooter
does not make you invincible or
infallible they have too many rights by
the look of it we need to restrict
scooter people here we go it's not over
yet look he's standing by the lake you
see what I'm saying yeah apparently they
fight all the time these neighbors look
he's totally fine he's walking totally
fine he can walk but he can't scoot
without the scooter right but my points
to walk yeah I mean look it's it's a
it's a better certainly better system
and wants to wear a shirt either
I'm surprised she was able to topple him
over you know cuz he's a big guy sitting
down it is one of the dangers of the
scooter makes it easier
you're susceptible to topples that's why
you got to keep moving you're on the
scooter you gotta keep moving
I love like a turtle on its back
these scooter videos I can't get enough
of yes bro you risk that when you park
behind her man this guy by the way like
let's appreciate the vantage point this
home is just an his he's peeking out of
a curtain just watching this all unfold
on his phone I mean that's a great
that's great so telling you scooter
people there's another yet another one
yet another one from been a of a crazy
scooter person watch this [ __ ] you got
to watch closely because it happens fast
and it's a little far off but you can
see a scooter person comment down the
road and they slammed through the
blockage I almost get run over you see
that again so here the car some old
person on a scooter come slam it through
the blockade and then almost goes run
over all the way to the to the curb yeah
powerful stuff it cannot stop powerful
powerful stuff
I love that the workers are like barely
reacting as if this isn't like the first
time yep certainly not like another
scooter person what do you think yeah
I'm considering getting as good yeah
when I'm old I might get a scooter and
just [ __ ] the world up I love this just
like pee [ __ ] your barricade [ __ ] Oh
help me and then it's like I'm stuck
help me yeah fantastic I love it now
this one's a little bonus clip it's not
to do with scooters but close it's a the
original scooter a horse so there was a
there was a an injury at a horse track
full screen good some audio and they for
some reason I don't know why they put
him on the back of a horse instead of
just carrying weight let me let me
interrupt real quick it this is actually
a demonstration that's not a real person
on the oh damn why would you ruin the
video are you sure about that
I'm 99% sure that that's a mannequin
yeah you got to keep that stuff here so
but so I don't understand why you would
put an injured person on a horse I mean
that doesn't make any sense especially
when they gallop for Christ's sake
imagine you have a back injury so maybe
you know if they're in the wilderness
you need to get somebody out of there I
choose I use to but just pretend it's a
real person you're right
yes all good thing so I've got a bad
idea to put a injured person on a horse
I mean you can easily just carry them
you know good resolution potato I did
did the resolution go down but anyway oh
there we go
so enjoy yeah I thought that was a real
person Dan if it was cracking up last
night
like it's like Lonny that I mean that
this poor injured person is put on
horseback and then look at him come like
what a disaster
look at that but it's not funny anymore
yeah you gotta keep that stuff they were
they were trying to show look at this is
like back-breaking right there so it's
like yeah maybe maybe we won't it will
just carry that horse is getting turn
into Chlo
for sure so that's it that's it so I got
a quick update on the salmon cannon here
yeah Elia was interested in the the real
the real issue that's being solved with
this thing so the the salmon they swim
upstream to spawn you know to reproduce
but then we build dams and they can't
get to where they do it so they don't
reproduce as much and then the salmon
population goes down so they're just
trying to they're trying to help them
you know get upstream a little bit more
efficient way and then a nice little
detail about this is apparently that
tube was made for transporting fruit and
the company was just like hey what if we
throw a fish in here I bet that it
worked right throat what the hell is
going on out there in the
what's with tube transporting hand is it
it's supposed to be for like apples or
some [ __ ] right yeah
and that won't last that like you'll get
it needs to have some kind of bouncy
some cushiony exit not unlike water I
guess right okay
okay I'm still skeptical though all
right my skeptical mind
I'm Way too woke to buy that chest voice
innovations um let's see what else yeah
whoosh I mean damn who you kiddin
cheddar what what are we talking about
here our Kelly is miserable in jail
because he is illiterate hit me with
that and unable to read fan mail
the singer the lawyer Steve Greenberg
spoke out on behalf of his client to
share just how miserable Kelly is
feeling behind bars he's a spiritual guy
he has a Bible with him in his cell but
he can't read it it's basically there
for comfort now he's been placed in the
MC C's Shu which incidentally is were
Epstein wise had it oopsie-doopsie
a cell and solitary confinement away
from the jail population and is
constantly being moved from so so he has
only the guards to talk to know what
kind of lawyer is this who is he working
for putting out this story I don't know
what's their motive just to get sympathy
for poor illiterate or Kelly girl did
you bring your ABCs today I derived here
we go
did you bring your ABCs
did you bring good night moon gorilla
Wong who really well I'm in prison
impression girl I just want to read the
Bible what are you doing three lamb
reader like that's the only thing you
can do in prison is read yeah did you
get your passports Jew gets his shots
girl I'm going to prison and I am
illiterate mr. Akeley you have been
served
boy I can't read this I can't read it
all girl did you bring your flashcards
yeah this is you know I go on all that
article also says that uh he's been
receiving a lot of fan mail but he can't
read any of it so now why would they put
this kind of information now it so you
think he's illiterate I've heard that
before
but you you raised a good point here
aight music and be illiterate I find
that interesting I mean besides I guess
he could tape it I mean he doesn't have
to write that lyrics down necessarily
that seems very difficult like coming
back the tape all the time or maybe his
people transcribing it but he can't read
it yeah what's the point
mm-hmm can you really be fully
illiterate article says basically
illiterate so you know
mmm-hmm what is the illiteracy
illiteracy rate in the United States how
are we doing on that look that up for me
so you 99 well we're killin it he is the
1% we are doing really good only he lit
it on literacy rates that's really high
it's not bad he's the only idiot in
America that can't read nice
I mean 99% that's still one in a hundred
that's still but like I I don't know why
I thought it would be lower yeah well
well you can't get a hundred percent cuz
there's always our Kelly that's very
true
you know 99 it's pretty much 100 percent
it's crazy back in the day reading was
like a luxury of the upperclassmen like
broke-ass peasants Nutt couldn't read
yeah it's true and they weren't allowed
to either like give me that book
[ __ ] slaves weren't allowed to
read yep they're like oh the slaves are
so stupid also give me that book before
you learn to read it's like which way is
it are they dumb or they can't or are
they not allowed to read you know white
people anyway let's move on so our
condolences to our Kelly who's miserable
in jail he's illiterate and unable to
read fan mail our hearts goes out to him
and his family isn't it crazy that now
he's just like done it's kind of cool
finally huh I mean it's a fall from
grace you know Epstein's fall from grace
was was an epoch we're gonna talk about
that later and we got too deep into it
but Epstein was a billionaire playboy
untouchable aristocrat friends with the
most powerful people in the world to
being suicided in a Cell I mean that's a
Shakespearean fall from grace you know
we'll get into that yeah but when it
comes to our Kelly it's just I feel like
it's kind of satisfying like if they
finally got it they did they found he
dodged it for so long yeah yeah his ass
is in jail man
not that I'm taking joy in him being in
prison but well I'm sure a lot of his
victims are yeah you know and family of
the victims so did you get your so how
about this how about a new rendition
did you lose your passport can you no
longer vote oh you're a convicted felon
in America merica did you get some books
to read oh wait you're illiterate do you
lose your passport as a felon I think so
I believe so I think so he's not going
anywhere
did you lose your passport did you get a
shot of come up your ass by a fellow
prisoner no either didn't like that one
the guy's a sexual being
obviously like sex so the chance of him
[ __ ] another prisoner they do that
they're gay for this day so I'm saying
there's a high chance that our Kelly's
gonna [ __ ] do it in there especially
if he's in there for life maybe the
lawyer will let us know we are are Kelly
is miserable as he has been forced to
have sex with men in prison he's a very
sexual man but as there's no women in
prison he has been forced to take a
giant load up his [ __ ] on a daily
basis we are sad to report this is our
Kelly's lawyer we are sad to report that
our Kelly has been forced to suck
another man's penis
it wasn't forced he did it by well but
out of sexual frustration
he has been sucking other men's penises
we're sad to admit because although he's
heterosexual there are no other women
and I know this is working yeah do you
have anything you want to report our
Kelly's lawyer
yes I would like to report that we filed
our Kelly's tax returns and he could not
read it so we scammed it out of all of
his money I'd like to put that out we
would like to report that that's
probably why he has no money left you
can't read you can't read I mean you can
read numbers right good point II though
we are sad to report that our Kelly is
living on a diet of guru yeah I feel
like if I was funnier I can pull it off
you know some days you have it some days
you don't and that's okay I never said I
was the funniest guy in the world
I never claimed that I only claimed that
we bring you that gives the laughs and
the news and the spooks every week the
spooks
that's my only guarantee yes the spooks
yes dan are you always saying to Danny
all right we're at 30 minutes so up next
we got twitch verse ninja I mean it's
going down ninja calls out twitch a big
time which is just soak what's a dental
because I was saying the same thing yeah
just like a week before you are kind of
a prophet and have turned right after I
am a prophet thank you for finally
acknowledging that also yang is is
flying high on that h3 bump I got to say
I don't want to take full credit for his
success but I also do yeah you should
he's in his donations are way up his
followers his campaign is killing it I'm
yanking all day he's apparently he's
raised like 2.6 million dollars so far
this quarter which is like already
double what he did the whole last
quarter so yang gang is flying high I'm
very excited I think he's got the Laker
it's like the only guy that actually
makes everything interesting and right
exciting for once
fresh vision yeah alright welcome we're
gonna throw two quick commercial break
we got twitch we got Epstein madness and
finally Ian get excited it's time to
find a date for jungian find the love of
his life here on 8 on The Bachelor
but instead of an H E it's H 3 kind of
you need a visual to see regardless guys
we will be back momentarily after this
commercial break
hi Dan I've been using this app Noom for
the past week and I'm gonna tell you
right now Ella I'm announcing today on
the show that I've lost four pounds Wow
and I'm gonna continue to lose weight
because this app noon is actually
fantastic let me tell you about it first
of all first of all to educate you it's
like a it's a it's an app that tracks
your calories and educates you about
food so like for example this morning I
had like oh and toast and and fruit and
all this and you put it in not only does
it count your calories for you but it
tells you how good of a color a calorie
investment that food is like how much
mileage how much fullness are you
getting out of that food you know and so
it tracks it educates you it keeps you
motivated and it you set a goal and it
tells you basically on a day-to-day
basis how many steps you should be
taking how many calories you should be
eating and there's somebody a real
person on the other end that reaches out
to you and keeps you accountable they
text you that's cool they message you in
the app if you have questions they're
like actually there to help you and keep
you honest but mostly important it's
about the education this is the journey
you know you weigh in every morning and
it tracks your progress I mean it's
phenomenal I have really been enjoying
the experience of being on on noon and
you guys are gonna see I'm gonna lose
the vote I've been looking for some to
really get me motivated cuz I have been
at my all-time fattest my all-time
fattest okay I was at 215 when I weighed
in
[ __ ] massive now I'm down to 210 just
slows and again I'm telling you because
it really keeps you on point and what's
its really been good for me is that not
only am i sticking to my calories but
I'm doing it in such a way that I'm
actually not starving all the time yeah
you're so eating pretty regular had a
really big breakfast but it was only 650
calories and I feel satisfied and that's
what's so beautiful you can look over
everything you ate at the end of the day
I actually learned a lot about specific
foods like you I figured having a bowl
of frosted mini-wheats
with almond milk was good but actually
it's it's a it's a bad food it's a lot
of calories and it doesn't fill you up a
lot
they don't recommend but but also it's
like they understand that you're gonna
have slip-ups too and they build that
into the program that some days you're
gonna have bad days some days you're
gonna have good days and they I'm
telling you it's great I see that they
describe it as a habit changing solution
and I totally agree with that
you can't just some starve for two
months and then hope you know to stick
with it you're just gonna go right back
to your old habits yeah so it's a foot
it's really a full system solution to
losing weight it's education it's habit
changing it's keeping you honest I
highly recommend giving it a shot
look this is what they say you don't
have to change it all in one day small
steps make big progress sign up for your
trial today at noon n o om dot-com slash
h3 so guys let's all start losing that
hoop together go to Noom comm / h3 and
start your trial today that's Noom calm
/ h3 the last weight loss program you'll
need
ladies you know how sometimes underwear
pinches in areas you just weren't
pinched yes hila you know about that all
the time
what are we pinching what are they
talking about ask crack the ass crack
what does it shove your ass crack
together no it's like Oh crunches up
here yeah and you know how sometimes
they just don't get it right and you
know how sometimes all you want to do
after a long day is take it off well
ladies me undies has a new line coming
out just for you it's called the feel
free collection designed with your butt
in mind you let's see what you got
so these things you hated about
underwear before yeah they're gone the
feel free collection was size tested on
every body type yes real bodies and not
a perfectly abortion mannequin real
sizing for real women still made with
the softest heck material and now what
instead come on what are we doing here
you're sitting down already give them a
twirl show him what's up and now a
feather-light waistband that provides
zero restrictions and more freedom twirl
offered in sizes extra small to 4 XL
let's see the back the feel free
collection comes in five new undies
silhouettes including a bralette or at
least the bra bra you let what or the
least bra bra you'll ever wear trust the
feel free collection is made with the
signature softer than clouds me undies
micro modal fabric to really cradle your
buns fun new prints drop every Tuesday
so you'll never run out of styles and
colors yellow how do you feel about your
me undies you want me to try it on okay
I love that it fits over the pants but
no that's not a real talking I'm kidding
I love the fabric and I do love their
prints they got the best prints in the
game this feels really comfy sometimes I
like a wear bra because my titties need
some support to be totally Frank van
Dee's has a great offer for my listeners
for any first-time purchaser you get 15%
off and free shipping it's a no brainer
especially because they have a hundred
percent satisfaction guaranteed that
means if you don't like it they're
thrown in the furnace they burn it you
get your money back there's no risk it's
all reward get 15% off your first pair
free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guaranteed go to me
calm /h 3 that's me on DS dot-com / h 3
m EU and di es dot-com / H [ __ ]
3
welcome back Fupa nation Ethan did not
come back from his restaurant break yet
so unprofessional that now you have to
listen to this
so twitch his ninjas channel to promote
other channels where is it
let's take it in a while oh god he's
like locked in the stall or something
there is where like back instance
yesterday alright we're back fairly how
long we've been back what are you
serious
sorry everybody hey Twitter world this
is yours truly so how did you hold it
down by yourself um well you will have
to watch and I'll have the water back
and you let me know probably horrible no
you did it's great
look at ya crushing it as always I
started reading your next topic which is
twitch
yeah let's just get right into that
twitch proving once again that it's such
a as a platformer vindictive [ __ ]
immature pathetic who's running this
ship man I complained that the minute
after I left come back to YouTube they
dropped me as a partner
which is something I had for years
before then when they owed me money and
I was trying to collect the money they
owe me they mate they're asking me to
sign backups into the partner program so
they could pay me so they did not only
did they do the same thing to ninja they
dropped him out of the partner
program but ninja posted this video
which I'll show with you guys right now
so so the story is that they've been on
his page if you go to twitch calm
slash ninja yeah they've removed his
[ __ ] and they're promoting other
channels there now it's almost like if
our channel we stopped posting videos on
h3 and then YouTube were just like you
go to the homepage you just see like
yeah yeah that's that's what they're
nice they're there right that's that's
what they're doing essentially and then
so but apparently what happened was that
so they've been promoting other videos
and then somehow somebody posted porn
and twitch and it's infinite wisdom
promoted pornography on ninjas homepage
and you know he's a very brand friendly
guy he's got a lot of kid viewers that
he he he knows that and he makes his
stuff appropriate for the younglings and
they're promoting porn I like the system
of failures and places is unbelievable
twitch what the [ __ ] here well here let
ninja speak for himself as you guys know
I'm streaming on mixer now my team and I
have made sure that the transition was
incredibly smooth super professional we
haven't said anything bad or negative
about twitch obviously because it really
hadn't been any reason to over the last
couple of days there have been some
things have been going on that you know
we let slide they were kind of annoying
little jabs we felt like but didn't
matter want to stay professional but now
those who don't know if you go to twitch
on TV slash ninja they advertise other
channels they don't do this for anyone
else that's offline by the way just me
and there are also other streamers who
have signed with other platforms who
stream and channel still remains the
same you can see their mods they don't
promote other streams they don't promote
promote other popular channels but they
do online
I've been streaming for 8 years to build
my brand to build that channel 14 and a
half million followers
they were still using my channel to
promote other streamers well now there
was a porn account that was number one
being recommended on my channel and I
have no say in any of this stuff so this
is like this is the line this is the
straw we're trying to get the whole
channel taken out to begin with or at
least not promote other streamers and
other channels on my brand on my freakin
profile so for anyone who saw that for
any ones whose kids or who didn't
obviously want to see that I apologize
and I'm sorry so crazy like it's one
thing to be promoting it on his page but
then how do you as a platform fail so
poorly that the number one recommended
one on his page is hardcore pornography
I just can't believe that he made a
decision to move to move to a different
platform that probably paid him more
it's a business decision and now they
treat him like [ __ ] yeah like trash like
he wasn't there for eight years exactly
and also why are you burning the bridge
maybe we'll come back at some point why
are you acting like he's dead and they
did the same thing to us and it's just
vindictiveness their patio child their
childish and I'm sure like we spoke
about the reason he left to begin with
is because they're being so penny pitchy
and so [ __ ] and not they weren't they
they're so annoying to work with that's
why we left ultimately but this is
taking it to the next level yeah so let
me open I have this picture I don't know
if I can show it
see I kind of want to show this I mean I
don't know come around and tell me if
you think I could show this take a look
at this yeah do you think I could show
this yeah yeah so here's what it looks
like we've censored it obviously the
streamer you're looking for is in
another castle
yeah is that also a job like the
language no and it was just a it's a dog
yeah a message that they have but check
out these [ __ ] but they're but they're
saying like hey he's not here anymore I
mean that's just strange but check out
these ones popular right now these
people are having sex how was that
that's number one how did that go on for
so long holy [ __ ] popular for tonight
channels I don't think that's for
tonight okay that didn't look like for
night to meet switch I wonder how many
people were viewing it number one and
this one and it was definitely two hours
by the way two hours yes who are you to
censor and black and everything how do
you even pretend to enforce the rules
when this is going for two hours one of
their biggest channels you guys [ __ ]
suck that is such a fail Wow amazing
the CEO of twitch responds let's see the
drama unfolds let's take a look at this
who is this guy I want to take a look at
this guy this guy's the CEO of twitch
you're wearing a [ __ ] he's wearing a
bowtie so look that speaks for itself
come on give me that the guys wearing a
bowtie
I have no problem all right Jesus eva is
uh he moves on where's our boat
everything done is come on Tim Gunn
always makes it work okay all right fair
enough our community comes to twitch
looking for live content to help ensure
they find great live channels we've been
experimenting with showing recommended
content across switch including on
streamers pages that are offline
specifically ninjas and no one else's
this helps all streamers as it creates
new community connections however the
loop content that appeared on ninjas
offline channel page grossly violates
our Terms of Service and we've
permanently suspended the account Oh
only because of the drama usually we
leave porn up we also suspended these
recommendations while we investigate how
this content came to be promoted well
that's probably a good idea regardless
of the fact that you're you know
utilizing his page you don't want to be
promoting hardcore pornography on a more
personal note I apologize I want to
apologize directly to ninja that this
happened it wasn't our intent but it
should never have happened no excuses
okay I feel very personal yeah that's a
good point
let me make a really general non
personal is a really good observation
you know well his wife Jessica ain't
having it she's not buying his response
she says twitch is doing PR right now
but it seems their intent from beginning
was to try and kill ninjas brand they
say promoting other channels on his page
was enough ill intent but here's a
twitch co-founder saying rip with a
winky face yeah now I actually followed
this this guy hasn't been involved in
twitch in years so he was like eh this
was his announcement video he said rip
he was just saying eh I don't think his
fans will follow him on mixer I don't
care I'm not involved in twitch but you
know whatever so he's not working for
twitch right now when that's what he
said I was looking at his response too
but you know I mean because when I saw
her tweet I was like that's really not
cool yeah I thought so too and then I
looked at his profile pic and well first
of all it doesn't mention twitch and
then he goes on to say
I haven't been involved with twitching
years just commenting as an observer
mm-hmm
I don't think audience will follow
streamers to mix or other platforms and
I think it's a smart move for streamers
to try to max earnings and you know good
for him for try that's all all right
it's a guy not allowed I don't know is
it I'm professional from the comment I
don't know no that's fine I think it's
fine he hasn't been involved but I think
it would have been different if he was
working there but I think she should
have quote tweeted mr. bowtie well that
guy's the CEO so I mean he's the one
that's blown as far as I'm aware but
regardless I agree their their
intentions are obviously nefarious so
yeah no twitches over party trending on
Twitter oh no the one and only twitch
swimmer was beaten up and robbed on
stream and twitch bans the pork head for
saying n-word well I'm not gonna watch
that clip yeah but apparently twitch is
over I don't see much in the way of that
supporting do i watch this door there
was like a bad idea that's always the
case with this why what is that
I'm out whenever I see something is over
it's clearly not over right that's how
you know it's not over yeah yeah that's
true has that ever ended anything no it
is over is over party so that's the
update guys just making good on my
promise to bring you all the booths all
the wait what would you call that story
was that a smash mmm-hmm
that was a I mean that was a that was a
twitch gasps hmm
oh I thought it was very interesting
that on the news they called widens what
Biden said about the rich kids and poor
kids they call it a gaffe yeah because
that's what the that's what the meaning
of a gaffe is it I never heard it in
such a serious note and like on the news
let me define what
f is for you because I've probably
ruined the definition for you an
unintentional act or a mark causing
embarrassment to its originator that's
what I thought it is but a gaffe I just
find it honey yeah he made a gaffe you
know I you know I'm serious
hmm poor kids can be just as smart as
white kids uh-uh I'm serious such a
great soundbite yeah right quickly I'm
gonna get I'm gonna just another
headline that was great
Verizon sells tumblr for ten million
dollars after Yahoo bought it for 1.1
billion in 2013 how about that for an
investment oh my god so let me get this
straight
Yahoo by Stumbler for 1.1 billion
Verizon absorbs Yahoo they banned
pornography the website tanks mm-hmm and
now III even heard reports that it was
gonna be sold for as little as 3 million
yeah and I was just looking that up an
article just published a short time ago
it's looking like that is confirmed 3
million bucks so I was like that I was
like damn oh I'll buy tumblr for 3
million dollars Dan raised a good point
I mean the overhead on that
[ __ ] company has got to be
crushing they don't make money because
they have like 200 staff staffers
they've got a shitload of hosting costs
probably cost 3 million dollars a month
just to maintain it right so it's
basically free it's a liability who
wants this right so from one point 1
billion to 3 million because there's no
porn in short and and you know what's
the [ __ ] of it is that pornhub wanted
to buy tumblr and Verizon said no cuz I
thought it would be a bad PR move you
know it's a bad PR move taking up 99.7%
loss on a billion-dollar purchase idiot
like Yahoo yeah you got to love the
Yahoo's like dying last gasp
of life was to spend a billion dollars
on tumblr they're like you know how we
stay relevant this is our were down to
our last billion we're gonna buy tumblr
that's crazy because tumblr for a moment
seemed like it was gonna be like not
going anywhere well until they banned
porn it was pretty much a stable yeah I
didn't realize that that and I mean I
know is that porn was such a big deal
but such a big part of it yeah yeah
apparently it was well actually I'm
curious why Alexa what's that website
attracts traffic yeah Alexa Alexa sir I
want to see there traffic before and
after the porn its Alexa rating yeah I
got it so this is gonna be interesting
tome blur calm although a lot of people
use that app so I don't know if that I
mean it still is ranked number 77 in the
world for traffic that's a lot of
traffic that's not bad yeah it's not bad
at all but what I'm looking for is a
graph Alexa rank I mean it's still
popping still popping number 49 in the
United States you know that's a really
good deal to buy that just no it's never
made money hmm
no I just put ads all over that [ __ ]
just ruin it it's like look I'm not
making money for don't they already have
ads I don't think so
does tumblr have ads well what I don't
spend time with tumblr you know the only
thing I used tumblr for was furry porn
and now that's common right but I'll
tell you most of the porn I saw on
tumblr was a really weird niche [ __ ] I
really [ __ ] up weird furry porn anti
I'm saying the weirdest [ __ ] I used it
for arts but so long ago and I don't
remember why I stopped well you had your
first viral hit on we had collectively
our first viral hit on tumblr stickers
one you I had did like a hard piece
where she had a bunch of fruits
yeah and it got reblogged a bunch and
that was our first viral hit yeah nobody
caught her though I know we were all
pissed off because she was got Reap
tumbled like that like a thousand times
but no one followed you got like 500
what am I doing wrong here I don't know
I still don't know still don't know to
this day but I secretly made a furry
porn account and I have like a million
followers in like overnight I'm talking
like a goat humanoid goat with a hue
like a [ __ ] 20 inch here that's not
free it's gotta be cute nope but he had
cute features like his dick had eyebrows
no you got to see this crazy born on
tumblr dude well you can anymore Oh
crazy I would see the [ __ ] and I'd be
like oh my god how like and and and it
had a lot of engagement to like really
crazy animal sad
humanoids you know I don't know like the
dick is the size of like it goes up to
the hat top of the head like the dick is
the size of his whole body you really
saw that are you making it up no no I
swear I'm telling you I'm not kidding
have any of you guys looked at porn on
tumblr no I mean I was aware that it was
the thing but yeah yes yes I can always
come did you ever see any of that crazy
[ __ ] I never dove that debug because you
just scroll and scroll scroll and then
you can't really avoid it correct so
what so you've seen it not like furry
porn [ __ ] maybe because I was typing
very copy
yeah all right well congratulations to
Yahoo for their epic investment and and
I'm glad that's paid off for you yahoo
has continued to be wise strategic well
yielding company and congratulations to
them now Ian
why don't you get your cute little lass
in here because it's time to play
Ian's future wife yeah the one and only
introducing Ian the intern that's right
he's cute he's thin he's young he's
gainfully employed you'll be sitting
right here and thank you with a bundle
of roses for me have a seat
keep the music going for christ sake
we're having too much fun in here yeah
yeah he's about 6 foot tall weighing in
at what I would guess is a hundred and
fifty pounds of how much 60 less what
he's a sick worm of 160 pounds he's hot
he's firing he's smart and he's got a
huge [ __ ] yep just like a giant furry
goat
that I can't verify but he does have
some huge red roses just dying roses
from last we see they're a little a
little iffy so we've got in there of
dozen roses I think that we need to
narrow it down probably - how many do
you think we should narrow it down -
because we have to hand out some roses
here today and we have to make some hard
decisions five five well let me see how
many contestants we have yeah I think
five is good because we have about ten
we have one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven yeah we're
gonna have to narrow it down to five Ian
so are you ready to play the h3 bachelor
a piece so bad
I don't you want to take a break without
opening your mouth if you want I don't
I'm not a puppet not Jeff Dunham's dog
do we have her to be able to play while
we do this because that's the same one
you play don't we have like back like
Dana music oh no dip we gotta call it
off we went over this last week
come on guys well we got we got a have
some dating music we could we did we
talked about this last week before we
went live that we have queued up no this
is good
Zack we went over it last week didn't we
to find dating music you never said to
pull dating music what well what do we
got oh my god oh we've let me pull up
yes
you guys keep experimenting with music
back yeah we're gonna pull up our first
contestant here so keep in mind this is
entirely their brainchild I did not
request this this is not I'm not just
like super horny and I was like guys I
got it it's not about horniness
it's about true love it's so weird this
is about I'm joking
are you single I am you are you ready to
mingle as all ever be let me introduce
you to Sarah okay by the way the goal
here is to find your wife this isn't
just to find like oh we're going on one
nightstand otherwise I'm not zero to 100
how do I you watch The Bachelor I don't
right away dude bachelor in paradise is
on and I'm gonna go home and watch three
hours bachelor in paradise tonight
that's nice bachelor nation how do i
fullscreen and then slide I don't know I
don't know what I'm doing you know your
point tutorial presentation you have to
click at the top and then how do I go
and that's base right key right yeah oh
that's that's self-explanatory okay so
for your consideration okay we have
Sarah okay hi Sarah appreciate you
coming out
that is me she says XO here we go Sarah
is age 18 and a half now how old are you
in is that within your acceptable age
I'm 25 you are yes
is that good or bad I can't wait I think
than that he was when I started
I've been anything working I feel like
there's a big difference between 23
which is when I first met you right
yeah 25 well regardless she's 18 and a
half she's 5 3 is that a little bit
under there well I think 17 would be too
young
let's say look look she's a sophomore
basically a sophomore she's a she's in
college she's not in high school right I
mean that's that's not acceptable it's
close
no it's freshman I'm guessing basically
a sophomore is freshman knows her dream
job is to be a medical examiner has a
rainbow tattoo and her hobbies include
arts and crafts she's enjoys watching
bad movies hmm oh I like the little
picture they're pros of dating me
doesn't expect anything besides love
well listen to you and respond back to
you right no buck Sophie's deep on the
meme too you know what that have you
heard yeah just want a bucket required
that's a dude that's a deep-water yeah
though she's a fan I appreciate this
next one this is good we'll never make
you listen a little nas X is baby-faced
like Belle Delphine now is that I don't
know if that's a were you in there Belle
Delphine I said I pulled back yeah but
she made a risk she made a risk here she
said I'm baby-faced can be the Mesa to
your light though I don't know what that
I don't know that one missed sorry Sarah
she took a swing on that one but okay
cons of dating me Texan ooh
that's literally the only con well
because she's not local is a distance
that is a distance pin hey thank you for
playing I would never call you that or
quote that soundbite usually you kind of
did like that's how you would do it
that's not how I do I'd never even bring
it up never
I respect everyone's bladder sighs I got
a piece so bad well here she's got a
bust of yours truly and I don't mean no
Jay says true power point segments are
the best both love Kanye U is cute Ethan
let me hit I like that's your choice
yeah what happened to me I'm down the
feminism here date ideas Sharky's don't
make me go there not Sharky so there you
have you Sarah I mean I this is a lot of
work I appreciate a good PowerPoint how
do you rate her slides her slides are
good there's just not enough transitions
no transitions there's a serious
there's no cackles big lack of Comic
Sans the fine mm not a lot of color you
mm-hmm that's model I mean but yeah I
think this is a lot of work put it I
really appreciate it there's some good
stuff in here do you want to make a call
on this now is she gonna get a row I
mean let's wait I mean I want to give
everyone yeah we should have you oh no I
can't do that now yeah but so I got a do
you have a do you know if you want to
give her a rose or do you want to wait I
I mean let's let's see a couple and okay
so that's Sarah okay so wait how many do
you have in there we have a lot of em so
buckle in more than five that's for sure
so here we go
let's present now if there's one that
really catches your eye I think you
should present the Rose on the spot yeah
okay so hi and please choose me I think
I'm a catch I like the colors all
transitions matter that was spicy my
name is Jesse 21 years old single and
ready to mingle
yes dad she's ready to mingle we could
buy new roses it's within the budget I
think these look better cuz they're
wilted like his heart yes now everyone I
don't want anyone to miss this
okay okay Wow yeah we have things in
common I love like a horse stretched out
yeah I need water to drink truth is all
these gonna relate to me having to go to
the bathroom take money I'm pop paused a
great music tastes great aspect ratio
that's great music tation at its place
666 Old Town Road there's a little
Heaven's Gate action down over colt
and the oculus oh yeah be good to your
mother capisce
this is a powerful powerful then I
really need to be right now
I guess that is true confirmed my sister
so that's one that she was uh go back
yeah this was Jesse Jesse so we've got
Sarah and Jesse no roses handed out yet
but we'll we may circle back I'm
admiring these powerpoints a lot to take
in
I hear you we did pick the best for you
some didn't preparing we had a lot that
we narrowed it down for ya so here we go
now now this is just a PDF but that's
fine so here why you should pick me for
a date a power presentation from yours
truly what up Twitter World Team Rocket
doing a DAB as well PowerPoint
presentation oh it's a PDF that's true
is that negaduck some points mmm
so I may not have Yeezys on my feet but
this does not mean the feet Ian your
power points always exceed expectation
which only contribute to my infatuation
I appreciate that
nice so tell me about yourself I hear
you say in a sexy voice sexually well I
guess I'm the one special I say and
blush rearranging my Prairie dress to
cover myself up as I'm not a depraved
harlot I giggle like an absolute [ __ ]
[ __ ] and climax on the spot wow that's
a lot of fans sonic was once lost but
now he is found in in Mick podcast
blessed is anyone reading this is like
what my hearing it's a mean I'm 21 years
old 5 foot 5 and I weigh 110 pounds I
wipe from the back white yeah that's the
right way to do it right no we're front
no but for a female or female you have
to yeah you have to what because you
want to wipe away from the badge
I want solidarity with you want you're
looking for a front of front wiping
female and this case viral a vital
requirement for a judge of character I'm
deeply interested in movies here my
current favorites ghosts and shout
sunshine to help kamikaze girls Dead
Poets Society Legally Blonde Harry
Potter Schindler's List War of the
Worlds is Dan and I just watched that to
you today it's good stuff really I
thought that Tom Cruise
you don't like Tom no I mean there's a
weird one cuz that's great okay sorry I
take it back you do like Tom Cruise I
like Tom Cruise I just don't like that
movie but I do think I do think that
Schindler's List should be at the top of
everyone's favorite right next to Harry
Potter I watch this every weekend do you
like cats well I got to one about them
that's good that's big I like this meme
so don't actually have two cats but I
[ __ ] with this meme heavy never mind I
like cats especially scrunchy ones in
the slide I'll exhibit some examples so
she's a cat admire from afar yes my
hobbies are drawing and making 3d models
here some of the stuff I make I study
video game development and uni so you
can say trump nein aid on us hard after
his whole video games cause violence but
I digress
I can also appreciate some nice fashion
I mean check out these dope slides brah
mmm I may not have a belly button lint
jar or rad soaping moves like Ryan Jones
miss but I can guarantee you I am just
the right height no bucket require
another denied yeah that's and here
she's said hot I like that little edit
there that's nice so in you know what
I've been holed out I there's a lot
going on I'll throw a rose Wow first
Rose is awarded here you have to present
to me what's your name wait hold on hold
on that rose
her name is uh wait wait when did she
say her name she just said yours truly
but we had a name so we have no name
what about the very end there
I think it's in the dock look where you
got this link from it just says date for
the lovely mm-hmm we don't have a name
wow that's can I give a rose still or is
that yeah you will call her the what do
we call her cat girl no that's no good
call her just the right height no
buckaroo Faro
but there was another one so well color
dabbing a Pokemon okay adding Pokemon so
you present the Rose like it's me hello
what it was well I've ever seen the show
how did they do it you have to say Ethan
and you need to smile at him and you
need to be like kana theory like you're
almost in tears mm-hmm basically me all
the time
and as I will you accept this rose
dabbing James from Pokemon will you
accept this rose it would be my great
pleasure that was that was a powerful
moment now you don't have to award all
5en so let's just keep it to the ones
that really interested you okay
so congratulations to dabbing I feel
special when you handed me that rose I
could tell the park so let's see let's
have a look at the next contestant I
want to get with people know the
bachelor with h3 I wonder if though at
least we got a name Zoe yeah thank you
what if she was down for you to pee on
her would you ever pee on a girl I have
no interest in Yuri I got a piece I
don't have to pee I think you would pee
on a girl that moment was right it
wasn't on okay well you ever peed on
anybody myself accidentally yeah but if
a girl and the heat of the moment was
like I want you to pee on me I probably
would what about you I had to pee on you
I wouldn't ask for that probably I mean
if a girl was like if that was her thing
that was her kink and it was like a
spicy moment and she said P no not on
the bed obviously like maybe in the
showers
something I'm just I'm delivering her
request though we're learning she want
if you want yeah I'll do it yeah if you
want me to do something weird I'll hook
you I have well then then we got no
problem but apparently the options been
there so well this might be into it is
my only point
okay she's 22 years old I like Ian I
think he's super cute and funny I've had
a big crush on him for a while now how
does that make you feel special plus I
think we have a very similar taste in
music is telling for power points
inspired me to make this I have a BA in
psychology and a minor in biology Wow
my focus was neuroscience Ian are you
hearing this ship so if he's at all
interested in that I could tutor him I
would get up at 5:00 a.m. for any
Coachella Kayne Church s concert for Ian
I also don't smell my period blood
hmmm well that's a good deed also
there's the what I like the layout of
this slideshow I don't think I could
make a slideshow yeah I mean the layout
is very it actually looks good I thought
that she was gonna be like a graphic
designer based on the layout she's not
okay well I have an issue here she says
hobbies and likes the first one is the
h3 HD podcast but as we all know that's
actually not the name of the show it's
the h3 podcast so that undermines her
pointing a little bit but well over all
overlooked that other hobbies anime
Scheldt what is shown in specifically
anyone back there can you clarify that
down I think Shonen is like the ongoing
series type of thing like bleach would
be a show name
okay good I like that playing the harp
Oh Oh interesting what are the rings
gaming she's a huge Nintendo fan girl
conducting EEG zon willing participants
that's good
isn't that like heart yes like a heart
monitor
yes that's yeah what is it
EEG someone looked that up would you
listening to Charli XCX
any but do you know what that is yeah
I've seen her three times she's a singer
you're a big fan yeah and it's quite
underground have you ever said that on
the show it's on my Instagram so she
maybe may have that little deep dive and
like sorry that an EEG is the monitor
like brain waves and activity yeah you
probably do need that I could use that
they're only trying to learn how to
embroider Ian yes I like that one I can
do a French inhale with my vape is that
good
dan is that good that's when you go and
breathe it in your nose right yep
dislikes ghouls it's like a zombie esque
that's a that's a reference to a TV show
what's the TV show It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia okay I do like that show
but apparently not as much as her yeah
honorable mentions I have a cute cat now
she reels for real contact oh [ __ ] did I
show it contact info wait hold on let me
I I censored it oh thank you thank God
okay good bring it back oh she's wearing
that kara church is very heavy cool very
hip address hopefully in Anne's heart
Instagram this is for you so in what do
you think I like there's a lot a lot to
like here I got a name is Zoe would you
like to present a rose - sure I'll give
Zoe rose okay so uh Guardian do we have
like any music for this yeah this is
what I'm talking about you guys are
blowing this beautiful moment I said
have dating music ready all they've got
is my P soundbite that's all you know I
don't ask much from you guys they said
have dating music ready
I need brosman I need rose ceremony
music at least Zak you got nothing what
about I'm looking I'm looking
still I mean come on you know yeah hot
give zakah rose dude think about what
you'll say I mean you know yes
there's this one well this is not right
I mean this is like like your kale oh
yeah this is like I'm getting a baptized
is this sack or you know this isn't me
sack this is come on this isn't a boss
fight here bachelor I swear did we not
last week in preparation for this pick
dating music you said take like a theme
song alright get me some romantic for
Christ's sake fry
should we do this one before we lose the
moment here I know how to make this
moment something nice will you take this
have the Rose what I couldn't say I
appreciate you they say will you accept
this rose will you uh take this have
this accept this rose with all my heart
prepare next time the steps were
throwing me off they're gonna make yeah
they're quite distracting mystery girl
yes well I think so these applicants are
coming in pretty strong right I mean
there's a lot how many do you have left
do you know there's a lot also all of
these ones that we're looking at are the
the newest set and I gotta say people
stepped up the game after you called
them out last week Ethan good yeah I'm
glad this one's a little strange the
format is not high level oh here I have
to present that's why my application for
in the intern you know hey I did me what
the passport song Zack that's romantic
thank you
we have a video oh oh what's up HD
podcast
I didn't see you there but well I have
you here
let me tell you about why I think I'd be
a good candidate for human what do you
think ants
Ian smiling he's a fairy
I appreciate the effort yeah I was not
expecting a video and yeah and a cut and
everything so this is pretty high level
so hopefully you can kind of tell that
I'm not just doing this about my
Instagram I'm just trying to get a date
my favorite member of the HD podcast
well maybe okay I have a fragile II Hugo
here else biggie and fan so if my
powerpoint is been throwing up or
anything
just line up so yeah I promise if we
ever did go out we would have a
[Laughter]
now on to the PowerPoint I was just the
intro that was a strong strong entry
that's an entrance right there that was
good
whoa holy smokes Who am I what's up I'm
Katy I'm a senior at Boise State
University studying GIS and French I
love the vault there is yeah oh kids
yeah she's a gizze major studying and
making hinges I love to volunteer with
Special Olympics girls on the run and my
local mobile library she's a saint in
other words as well I'm a registered
yoga teacher I teach hot yoga and a
bunch of different beginner level
classes of all different styles wow I
like this angel yoga thing here is that
just on the wall cuz it's so dramatic
Thanks
she doesn't have actually have angel
wings I fly planes I'm working my way
through different license and ratings to
become a commercial pilot one day so I
can fly you wherever you want
wow that's great awesome mm-hmm
I'm always down for cool things like
skydiving re-enacting my favorite
internet social experiments hiking
boating going hard at Coachella for
Kanye and so so much more she likes to
have fun yes fun is good I like fun
fun is fun fun is fun well so I gotta
say but I'm still really chill I have to
binge watch shows on Netflix in bed with
tea some of my deal nights are watching
a free podcast with my dogs now Ian if
you dated this girl would you be able to
watch back page three podcast with her
she'll have to do that on her you know
she'll have to catch up on her own and
you guys could talk about the podcast I
mean that'd be great yeah I'd probably
have to excuse myself for those yeah her
dogs look awesome
yes cute dogs very cute pros of Katy no
apparent Illuminati connection
impeccable sense of humor I agree
also fan of Kanye that's Hans lives in
another state but she's also a pilot she
offers the
alternative there so that's good cares
too much very funny
I don't know that that I'm not sure she
sold that as a con I would enjoy a nice
meal at Sharkey's with you any day
I like the Photoshop Joe oh man thank
you for viewing my part by her getting
married to Ian with Kanye of 50 I mean
that's that's the dream right there
well you're getting short on roses you
only have three left so the thing is
that that video is a lot of work here's
what I'm gonna tell you in you can go
but you can recant on roses you can
renege on your row that's okay but I'm
just saying you make the decision now
why off the video alone I gotta give it
rose
so okay congratulations - I don't want
to jump the gun if there's you know you
can recant but this is Katie's time and
so go ahead Ian you got some yeah it
would be my greatest honor and privilege
to accept this rose from your today
thank you I love you and I cannot wait
for our night in the fantasy suite
did you watch Big Brother you can talk
to some bad I what Big Brother takes too
much time
Big Brother I tried watching that show
it's [ __ ] weird I'm all judging you
for watching Big Brother and I watch I'm
gonna watch three it's so good it's so
it really just gotta get the
understanding of all the mechanics so
let's not digress too hard here
I hope let's see so we are down here now
we've got it from Ashland Ashlyn overall
this is fantastic
yes you're down to two rows I think
there's gonna be a lot of jealous guys
out there because you were getting a lot
of good offers here two roses left in
cells at home are super pissed right now
Ashlyn is this original drawing on our
resume so this one's just a resume
I I like the drawing her objective is to
get some hot in ass it's a good at work
for a YouTube channel huh age 23 likes
video games Norse myth miss mythology
cartoons punchline rap what the hell is
that I think it's like jokey like lines
that are funny
like Lil Wayne sometimes does stuff like
that I think I may be wrong she may be
like I changed my mind better than you I
want to redact she dislikes and you know
I'm with you I hate sand
I hate Disney live-action remakes
writing resumes but I did this for you
the college educated at Texas A&M with a
Bachelors of Science and visualization
seems like none of these people live in
California doing so far live in
California which is probably that's a
bit of a negative I'd have to say it's a
big-time negative we're gonna have to
reach out and see everyone in LA is like
I think some of these might live in LA
let's not jump the gun but we look we
have a budget here and we can make
things happen one of them is even a
pilot my family owns land in Texas so
you have a great safety net mm-hmm rich
family yeah I can go huge fan of your
powerpoints I have a cute kitten
his name is ghost and I can't draw weird
things for you Collin smile drawing is a
lie I'm actually really bad at winking
here she is what there's the cows
I was wondering for the cat picture but
this for that okay so this is it yeah
that cat is amazing that's a cute cat I
was just saying to Dan there is no ugly
cat we tried to find one eat there isn't
one okay come on give me a break there
they already like you in I mean just you
don't have to endure and that was a real
conversation we had but you down the two
roses she's in Texas I appreciate the
work now I feel like an [ __ ] not
giving a rose out I want to give
everyone roses it's a lot of work she
had to draw a thing well yeah that's how
the show goes
so you have
this is a no for Ashton we're working a
hard decision a hold on okay Ashland
thank you for the effort Thank You
Ashlyn but that's an that's a hard no
from you I would give all the roses out
so here's one you know this one they
didn't include a picture so this is a
going on too long or something so let's
let's cut to the chase
another Ashlyn huh Wow yeah like I said
I mean I think the quality is gonna
decline over time since we're going back
in time here I mean this this is barely
this is not good enough I feel like
compared to what we've been saying I'm
sorry yeah well I've never put together
a resume look okay Ashlyn a Ian's future
care chassé hop enthusiast appreciate
your film favorite Kayne album is
graduation and late registration do you
approve of those late registration is
that's a good pick
are those deep cuts are obvious picks
late registration I feel like is a bit
of a that's that's like okay I see real
fan kit I see you a vibe really enjoys
film photography and if hired as your
care we'll take portraits and be your
personal hypebeast that's cool knows how
to play autumn on atone theremins cello
slightly above average when it comes to
Magic the Gathering can't play any
supports but pretty good at Chinese
chess knows how to use PowerPoint well
why didn't you make a PowerPoint because
it's like a tease like you know I could
make one damn you know I'd where did she
love it she's in San Diego oh well there
hey you want one of these how many how
many more do we have let's see here's
why because there's too many of these oh
my god there's so many more let's just
wait really like we can cap it okay okay
let's given all the options and then you
can choose okay so here's this is Ashlyn
okay you want to give me a rose cause
there's a lot more you only have one
left
well here I'm gonna I'll remember Ashley
I remember it's in my head name let's go
have to peace so bad
here let me hit let me do you some help
here so this one I'm gonna see where
they live like like this girl said she's
in England so Oh across the pond
this one's just pictures but hey we used
to live that's true the word is true but
so this one she says I have attached my
resume but I don't see a resume probably
could polish this segment a little more
yeah yeah this girl doesn't have a
resume sorry
25 year old photographer I like Kanye
before it was cool I don't know when
that was dating aberration free and lean
mean mean machine let's see what we got
here
so exactly we have any music at that-air
here this is a great one okay yeah Jess
Jess I'm nineteen applying for the
position of IANS uh wait friend sorry
did you uh get the memo on this we're
not looking for a friendship friend she
there's an Australian we can be friends
there you go we're friends okay we're
friends sorry your friend she put a lot
of work into this I'm friends with all
of you but we really the segment's gone
on way too long so apologies
twenty-two-year-old Eastern Europe I
mean come on what are we doing with this
oh this is a dude
are you interested he's got braces
that's uh that's cool he says if we
would we would look more into this but
Rene here's my resume let's see and I
haven't seen any oh my look at this Ian
hi Renee what do we got here Harry
Potter world that's nearby look at this
she's uh Wow got a crib where when do
you ever wear a gown like this you the
dinner with the beef collectin
I'm good Ian amis let's see let me read
about her she's a 21 year old flight
attendant Vanna Kanye well it's the
whole he just wrote it I'm not part of
any secret forum I'm a national pageant
titleholder and came top five in the
world the powerpoints are amazing keep
it up my favorite movies is anything
Bollywood just kidding it's Harry Potter
I love food and I aim to constantly eat
healthy so I don't have to keep holding
interventions for myself I love to make
people laugh but often at my expense
all my Instagram captions are pawns
which is probably why my Instagram model
career has not blossomed oh I'm
Australian but you wouldn't mind doing a
90-day fiance visa oh well there you go
can you imagine if we season with him
well I think that there is some interest
but unfortunately you are in Australia
well that you pretty yeah I mean I'm
trying to move it along here ya know do
your thing do yep yeah I would give a
rose if she was in LA I'd give her a
rose right now yeah
forgive you the bouquet okay girl damn
so Melissa and she's animated you guys
making a hump Wow he's also an Australia
dude you're huge in Australia I kind of
get tossed raelia you gotta get there
quick sorry you're in Australia we got
it that's a pasture mouse we gotta move
it yes wait longer than I expected
apologies to everyone here
I may have to retroactively Lee then go
back give a rose to this you know their
second choice they're not interested
anymore
- the last PowerPoint this one is boring
oh well that's it that's it that's all
so Ashland gets rose kept her so play me
the yeah so go ahead make your proposal
Ashley will you take this road so you
have except Singh as you passed me over
in consideration of other people I will
not accept this rose from you if you
don't what I will I'm refusing the road
these unplanned beats and I'm not
knowing Plan B I said I want to I will
come back and remember the name okay in
consideration of the fact that you did
say that
then I will with all my heart and all
the love of my body and soul accept this
rose means thank you appreciate I
appreciate your cooperation
there was the first girl or somewhere
that we I'll give it to the resume right
is that I think it was the Texas girl
write the word there was this power
point here that I think we owe with the
aspect ratios and yeah this one
oh the swing anyone okay yeah Jesse can
have a rose yes I will give Jesse room
so go ahead so Jesse will you accept
this rose him I was frankly insulted
that you passed me over as the firt one
of the first power points to appear I do
understand and any self-respecting woman
at this point would not accept this rose
and so I must decline I do not want the
road so I just keep the road is what I
would today was expecting rejection but
I will I will accept in consideration of
how sweet and kind and cool you are
I will accept this rose on behalf of
Jesse let's see yeah
so we have five roses for five terrific
girls Wow roses are looking a little
rough we're gonna have to do we're not
gonna buy new ones either this is gonna
continue to well so we have five
beautiful roses for five beautiful girls
here at the h3 bachelor in paradise well
I think this is season one we're in the
contestants aren't so we're gonna have
to reach out to them Dan's gonna have to
reach out we're going to find out a
little bit more like where do they live
we're gonna have to devise other ways to
kind of to separate themselves from the
crowd okay maybe a video and I think
that one girl made a video but maybe
they could tell us a little about
themselves and then we're gonna have to
we're gonna have to pick a winner
okay what is what is the end goal here
is the I go on a date is that that's the
goal yeah okay well marriage is the goal
to be frank okay so we're gonna have to
call I think we have to do another round
and call it down to two or three and
then a final round where you pick Oh
your match okay all right spicy yeah I'm
so thank you to these three beautiful
thank you for or else we're all so
beautiful you're all so inventive and
wonderful I think you're fantastic and
I'm sorry that in and his heartless and
carelessness did reject some of you I
did not i if it was up to me I would
have given everyone a rose
give all of these out we've got enough
to pass out all right take these take
these and get the hell out of here Ian
everybody
[Music]
wait is this not copyright no.3 oh
really
don't spicy so thank you in the h3
bachelors well tune in next week to find
out what these five beautiful girls have
on that to win the heart of ear D in
turnout right everybody tune in to the
h3 Network exclusively on the h3 podcast
I'm your host me tagline saying doctor
hi everybody
until next time we're not actually done
we have talking about Epstein okay how'd
that go we'll all raw mm-hmm that's how
we like it
yeah and I guess we could have rehearsed
a little before yeah we should have we
should have ironed that out a little
yeah so apologies to their listeners it
wasn't that bad all guys I know I like I
really like what all the girls put
together yeah those girls are something
mom I would give everyone a rose if I
could well let's talk about epsteen
epsteen is a first of all the guy what
was his first name Jeffrey Jeffrey what
a name Jeffrey Epstein is this creepy
ass looking [ __ ] he always looks so
smarmy and every photo I've seen of him
he looks like something about his face
right are you putting it on yeah like
something about this guy's face just
ain't right you know
so he's notorious for sleeping with
young girls but also sex trafficking
young girls and was recently locked up
locked away serious crimes and he is
associated with the rich and famous and
powerful of the world
he owns a private island where he would
reportedly be having affairs with
underage girls and he kept a little
black book what can I not zoom what is
this conspiracy there's a picture of
Trump in him and I can't zoom on it he
would fly on his private plane to his
private island and he kept meticulous
records of everyone who would come on
his island and on his plane for example
Bill Clinton flew on his plane to his
Island 20 times technically there's no
evidence that he went to the island but
he did fly on his plane all jet-setting
around the world okay his his airplane
was nicknamed the Lolita Express for
those of you don't get the reference
Lolita was a book about like a little
girl who seduced older men the Lolita
Express he was tried some time a while
ago and received some very Shady
sweetheart deal that allowed him to
serve his time basically he served a
one-year prison sentence and most of the
time he was allowed to leave prison and
work from his office
it was a scandalous scandalous plea deal
that didn't baffled people but on
recently new evidence came to light and
the gavel came down hard on Jeffrey
Epstein and Jeffrey Epstein has a bunch
of sealed documents in which he names
very famous powerful people that he
spent a lot of time with on his airplane
and on his island when he was in prison
a lot of people thought the Domino's
were gonna come tumbling on this huge
child sex trafficking ring he attempted
suicide apparently in his prison cell a
week ago and now it came out just a
couple of days ago that he successfully
committed suicide even though he was on
suicide watch and a maximum security
closely monitored prison cell which has
a lot of people wondering what actually
happened and how that's possible so
let's let's looking into this it's a
fascinating thing I mean it's the talk
of the town everybody's talking about
this because the scope of this
conspiracy yeah let's not mix it's not
mixed these seconds the scope of this
conspiracy seemed so huge from our
current President Trump to former
President Clinton to the royal family
these people who are all associated even
their previous prime minister in Israel
Prime Minister in Israel exactly are all
Associates of Jeffrey Epstein and a lot
of it was it was expected that a lot of
these people were gonna be in a lot of
trouble from what came out of this
arrest so there's there's a lot and a
lot of outrage to I mean it's in my
whole long life I have never seen what
seems to be such an apparent obvious
conspiracy such a brazen and cover-up
well that was so I was thinking I was
like it's so obvious that it was a
conspiracy that the consequences of not
doing it were so grave to whomever
perpetrated this mm-hmm that it was
better to have what was such an obvious
conspiracy to murder him or at least to
assist in his suicide
that they would rather risk being caught
or exposing themselves than risk Epstein
actually going through with this trial
so they were in such a tight place that
for them it was worth it I don't see how
it could possibly have been anything but
a conspiracy to end this investigation
it was announced Saturday morning that
Jeffrey had been found dead hanging in
an apparent suicide in his Manhattan
jail cell
now this tweet I think really summarizes
it really well if you want to understand
what an absolutely enormous scandal
Epstein's death is understand this and
the whole American criminal justice
system no inmate was more in danger
of suicide or homicide than Epstein and
everyone in law enforcement knew it and
now despite all that Epstein still died
mm-hmm I mean that's pretty incredible a
despite you know his alleged suicide
just two weeks ago he was taken off
suicide watch just six days later and
put back into the special housing unit
with our Kelly apparently next door that
maybe that's why he killed himself
Jack danced in a former longtime Federal
Bureau of prison case managers told NBC
News that suicide watch in federal
lockup usually only lasts a few days to
a week due to the amount of manpower
than 24-hour surveillance entails well I
guess that's counter conspiracy but
that's all it requires staff to do the
overtime not considered a good use of
resource I mean that's just such
[ __ ] maybe in a normal case that
would make sense but we're talking about
the biggest high-profile conspiracies of
all time according to the Washington
cases well I mean nobody his consent
criminal conspiracy oh I see you know
according to the Washington Post guards
were supposed to be checking on him
every 30 minutes but at the time of his
death hours had passed and nobody had
checked up on him there was supposed to
be a cellmate in there with him but his
cellmate had been transferred on Friday
and not replaced authorities have not
yet given an official explanation for
why he was taken off of suicide watch
however Jeffrey Epstein was taken off
suicide watch in part at the urging of
his defense attorney
apparently sources familiar told ABC
News
additionally federal authorities have
indicated that a suicide was not
captured on camera despite the fact that
the cells are supposed to have cameras I
mean what the [ __ ] how is it possible at
every corner his cellmate is gone the
guards are gone the cameras are off New
York Times reported that one of the two
people guarding Epstein when he died was
not even a full fledged correctional
officer and neither guard had checked on
Epstein for several hours before he was
discovered it is also worth noting that
the last suicide in this prison cell the
MCC was 21 years ago in 1988 1998 excuse
me so this is not a common occurrence
this is something that they're very good
at preventing 21 years ago Attorney
General William barramundi said we are
learning of serious irregularities at
this facility that are deeply concerning
and demanding a thorough investigation
mr. Barr said he did not elaborate on
what problems he was referring to but
that he said we will get to the bottom
of what happened and there will be
accountability
I'm staudinger mm-hmm an OPS an autopsy
has been done but the results have not
been made public yet
and an interesting twist
Epstein's lawyers hired a third-party
medical professional to perform another
autopsy dr. Michael Baden mock dr. Baden
is a famous pathologist who performed
forensics on JFK and MLK Jr two very
high-profile conspiratorial murders and
he was also a expert witness for the
defense of OJ Simpson immediately in the
wake of his appearance who said there
was a massive outcry on social media and
the conspiracy theories kicked into high
gear now dan what's the significance of
dr. Baden is this guy somehow being is
this and what's the implication I mean
the implication is just well first of
all he didn't perform an additional
autopsy he was just requested to be
there as an observer which I guess is a
common thing to be done it's just like
there are lots of people that do this
and the one guy that you get is somebody
that's tied up in the JFK assassination
and am okay you know what like you said
killings that to this day are very
controversial and have conspiracy
theories floating around it if you want
to seem like you're on the up-and-up why
do you bring this guy in you know what I
mean
it's just weird this guy defended OJ
Simpson yeah he was part of the he
wouldn't expert with witness for the
defense
you know Jays trial hate Twitter world
it's me doctor bended beddin which by
the way out one of OJ 's lawyers is Alan
Dershowitz who is Epstein's lawyer so
there's a connection there too so it's
all all these people it's all the same
circles you know what I mean mm-hmm
well wasn't Alan Dershowitz one of the
guys who flew on his plane yeah exactly
interesting now he's implicated in the
whole sex trafficking thing as well so
so now on social media there's lots of
trending tabs including Clinton body
count which was retweeted by the
president the sitting president of the
United States which I'll get into and
Trump body count so we can't decide
which president
responsible for the murder of I've seen
but they're both buddy-buddy with this
[ __ ] guy
there are many wealthy and powerful
people linked to Epstein who would
potentially want him dead to cover up
their involvement in crimes including
former President Bill Clinton Prince
Andrew of the British royal family Alan
Dershowitz dura wits that's the guy we
just spoke about his lawyer a former
prime minister of major nations and
speculated to be Tony Blair a a hoot
Barak former Prime Minister of Israel
and many others Trump tweeted which
caused a lot of stir in the mainstream
media this absolutely like the president
the [ __ ] president oh wait no no
where's the video did he retweet this
yeah what is it
just look at the top tweet what he
actually tweeted is that just that
breaking documents unsealed yes to
reveal that top Democrats including Bill
Clinton took trips to oh how to file
Island yeah but so did Donald Trump B&L
news oh it's like total partisan it's
like dude okay whatever yeah but the one
that I'm looking for is that video do
you not have that one I didn't see that
I mean I think he Unruh tweeted a lot of
these things including he didn't uh
there's this black guy talking about the
Clinton body count that he retweeted
okay I thought that I'm on his Twitter
right now I'll grab it
man this guy tweets a lot however
however that what he saw in at any rate
this is everybody's response to the
government's claim that he had committed
suicide and that it wasn't actually a
conspiracy a Vista
not this time it's totally me t the
media Jeffrey Epstein committed suicide
literally everyone else it's fiction
it's fiction I made it up we made this
one up it's a made up to vacation it
never happened it never happened this
one was invented by a writer that has it
never happened is false it never
happened it's fiction it's an urban
legend that never no way we got you we
got Jess not this time it never happened
it never happened we made this one up
did you find that one yeah I just put it
in this with you this is the one that I
saw Donald retweet because it's like
such a [ __ ] post conspiracy theorist I
was like oh my god the [ __ ] president
retweeted this garbage um where is it
you just give me his a link to his
Twitter account you just scroll past him
just like shaking my head I'm not
surprised I told y'all last month this
was going happy but did not body want to
listen all right he retweeted this diet
of suicide on 24-hour suicide watch Yeah
right how does that happen I'm with you
Jeffrey Epstein had information on Bill
Clinton and now he's dead I see Trump
body count training but we know who did
this actually I didn't see I said I just
saw Clinton body count so and you know
what he says the president I'm not
surprised I told y'all last month this
was gonna happen but did nobody want to
listen to me but then guess what next
money he did and you know what all the
Liberals were calling me a conspiracy
theorist sanitarians you come up with
crazy conspiracies and you need to be
banned from Twitter and then guess what
the man really ended up dead and you
know um he retorted this guy I don't
know why they're possibly trying to make
it a political issue there was people of
all over the spectrum including Trump
himself yeah I mean here's an imager
album
of people with who were hung hanging out
regularly with Epstein Bill Clinton as
you've heard Donald Trump who by the way
Epstein has a little black book that he
kept contact with his closest contacts
with he had 14 different numbers for
Donald Trump 14 different numbers here
he is once again with Donald Trump on a
different occasion here is so this is
this is wild this is his girlfriend at
Bill Clinton daughter's wedding what's
the story with her
that's his so this girl was Epstein's
girlfriend and allegedly in charge of
according to the victims who are now
grown up said that she was in charge of
grooming and recruiting little girls
into his service here he is with Prince
Andrew and pretty incredible stuff you
know Trump here this is a great video I
mean again I don't know where Trump gets
off doing with this whole Clinton body
count here he is so the story with this
is that there's a party with all these
young girls and it's just Trump and
Epstein they're the only two guys
she's hot
but it did make that sounds crazy
yeah I don't know if that's the security
guard or what
I mean but what do you mean that it's
just the two of them can you look that I
swear I read that yeah
Trump and Epstein party there was a
story yeah here listen party planner
surprise just Donald Trump and Epstein
and 28 calendar girls I have 28 girls
coming Donald this is supposed to be a
party with VIPs you're telling me it's
just you and Epstein in 1992 Trump
organized a party of calendar girls
it was just Epstein and Trump and the
women that's it I mean this guy looks
like a guard or something that works
there I don't know if this is that
specific party though either yeah I
could be talking out of turn here but I
mean look this is a guy who's friends
with Jeff in fact if Trump almost looks
like he's embarrassing Epstein more than
the other way around
he's like tone it down dude they're not
underage another knowledge for sure
other stories are way worse but underage
girls yes that's the certainly the
scandalous yeah the scandalous thing
about Epstein but here we have some
notable incidents people associated with
Epstein by either flying on his plane or
in his black book rolodex Bill Clinton
flew on his plane 26 times one time
that's like dude that is so many times
yeah my best friend's I even hung out 26
times with Kevin Spacey and Chris Tucker
along with Bill Clinton took a trip to
Africa with him isn't that funny
what a weird group of dudes Donald Trump
just revealed to have flown on his plane
in these unsealed documents last week 14
phone numbers for Donald Trump in his
black book
what is that Prince Andrew Larry Summers
former Treasury secretary president of
Harvard University
Alan dirt dirt Darrell woods Dershowitz
dursa which mix Mick Jagger Courtney
Love billionaire Leslie Wexner owner of
Victoria Secret Bed Bath Beyond and
several other major retailers New Mexico
Governor Bruce King former New Mexico
Governor and Democratic presidential
hopeful bill Richardson Peter soro the
nephew of George soro John Glenn
astronaut and politician former Israeli
prime minister Ahad Barak Naomi Campbell
so weird miss Sweden and socialite New
York dr. Eva Anderson Dubin the guy was
well-connected and I've also got a read
and correct me if I'm wrong nobody
really knows where he made his fortune
yeah it's super weird he's a billionaire
nobody knows well somewhat so that guy
that you mentioned the Leslie Wexner
yeah the guy that owns Victoria's Secret
and everything he apparently gave him
his start so to speak he gave him like
half a billion dollars or something
crazy like that for an investment fund
you know like a hedge fund and that's
what people always said is like oh he's
like a hedge fund guy but yeah now that
he's under all the scrutiny apparently
people have looked into it and that
nobody can point to anything this hedge
fund ever did like the money is just
kind of in limbo well the IRS certainly
should know where he got his money from
well I mean assuming the the criminal
case continues forward which it probably
won't now that he's dead I don't know
and who knows what will and won't come
out well my my guess is that nothing
will come of it the interest will wane
obviously over time and all these
politicians who are implicated in this
including the president who's now so
outraged and talking about Clinton body
count well in a month's time forget
about it
and nothing will overcome of this
investigation one of the most brazen
murder / assisted suicides I've ever
seen
maybe you've ever I've ever heard of
when the one of the biggest conspiracies
of a organized child sex trafficking
yeah believe this stuff exists that's so
crazy
it's it's unbelievable a whole island
for he owned an island off the Caribbean
pedo activity [ __ ] crazy man well
there you have it
end on a high note yeah it'll be
interesting to see what happens over the
next couple weeks I mean I hope it
doesn't get dropped well yeah but but I
understand why you feel that way at the
end of the day the people can only
demand so much it's like you got the
Attorney General has to invent I heard
the FBI is investigating that's good
heard the Attorney General I don't trust
him
I don't [ __ ] trust that Flint that uh
Fred Flintstone asked the [ __ ] for a
minute he does look like Fred Flintstone
by the way a little bit yeah yeah I mean
a guy in Trump's administration was the
guy that that gave him the sweetheart
deal back in the mid-2000s or whatever
that guy now resigned I think kind of as
a result of all right right right but
yeah I mean you know people trying to
make it partisan in it to me it's
everything yeah everyone and everything
this is just about powerful people being
sickos what I'm saying is don't trust
the people who are making a partisan
mm-hmm right yeah because they are
intentionally trying to involve
themselves yeah totally
and if you're gonna if Trump is gonna go
out there and tweeting Bill Clinton
conspiracy theories which by the way I
agree Bill Clinton was inexplicably
wrapped up with this guy it's totally
Trump is equally wrapped up with this
guy yeah there's no escaping that you
cannot have it both ways
mm-hmm the big defense that people give
for Trump is that you know he's
supposedly had a falling
with him when when when he got caught
basically around that time timing right
exactly it's like oh yeah he had a
falling-out with him when he got caught
for being a pedophile would say that's a
good time to disassociate with somebody
- yeah which yeah I mean to be fair you
know if you found that out about
somebody you knew you would disassociate
with him or if you did or or if you were
doing it with them and you're saying hey
yes exactly
I mean that's the point is it doesn't
doesn't here anybody of anything yeah
exactly I mean Bill Clinton may have
disassociated with him - he's not saying
anything about it he probably did Bill
Clinton on his plane around the same
time yeah from what I understand to
Clinton actually lied about how because
before the latest round of revelations
came out he had said that he had flown
with Epstein about five times and then
this flight was already bad right it's
not even 20 right it's a big difference
between five and plus so 2026 at least
that's once a week for half a year that
that is so many times you know what one
I actually just saw this morning I
should add it to the list that made me
real sad is Matt Groening the guy who
created the Simpsons right on the flight
logs yeah I read a little anecdote about
that that so the anecdote I read was
that he was flying on on the plane and
he received a foot massage and the girl
went into detail about how disgusting is
fewer that she had to go to the bathroom
and get a towel so this was one of the
alleged victims yeah in her testimony
she didn't say she didn't say anything
happened other than a foot massage but
then somebody pointed out and again this
is just someone on Twitter pointing it
out and I don't I don't actually know
but apparently the girl at the time was
14 years old and Epstein was like hey go
give him a foot massage and so I mean
it's a fortune you turn down that foot
massage
like I don't know man that whole world
is so [ __ ] so insane I don't know I I
I'd like to know how many people are
actually Jeffry ABS to invite you on a
plane ride you say no yeah that's the
Redis it's just so wrong that they
didn't catch it and now we're just stuck
with all this conspiracies and no one's
gonna know anything because this dude
Edel the fact that they let this guy die
is just I mean a pro if just it's so
[ __ ] up it's the most brazen cover-up
I've ever seen but that's why they they
had to be brazen because the alternative
was just they had too much to lose these
people I don't know you know no camera
yeah really
a most high-profile prisoner in the
whole country I wonder what they what
kind of information they have from the
investigations but I wonder if they'll
make it public anyway I hope so I mean
the FBI is looking into it which is
independent mm-hmm so I don't know man I
really hope so too
we'll see Walker will follow up on this
on the podcast and see who's what
politicians are kind of letting this
slide I bet you Trump's gonna
conveniently forget about this in a
month and so will the Attorney General I
guess we'll see I mean you'd think that
if if he actually does think or suspect
or even know I mean if he he's the
president if Bill Clinton was involved
somehow of all people he would know so
if he lets it slide it's like you know
he [ __ ] hates the Clintons yeah why
would he not go after a good point Dan
so I think in a month if Trump and
attorney general Barse done talking
about this and there's been no
resolution
that's the guilty that's the stamp of go
yeah that's it let's see we'll see what
happens with it I think nothing will
happen I really do
I hope you're wrong but I think you're
right yeah
well that's it for this week on h3
podcast I can't wait I can't wait to go
home and watch three hours of The
Bachelorette bachelor in paradise sir we
have a babysitter today so I'm gonna be
like I by Theodore mommy and daddy are
watching bachelor in paradise
[Laughter]
it sweet sweet hey me with that music
wrap me up all right start starting the
tune do you have your passport user can
you read me a book girl I wish I was
literate I don't like the pacing of this
one messes me up yeah I kind of anyway
guys thank you for watching I'll be back
Friday be back on Friday what more is
there to say I mean thanks for tuning in
thanks for being here we love you we
appreciate you and that's a wrap eh I
still feel like it's Friday every time
we do the Tuesday you know yeah well
it's not you know still it's still new
for us the two I enjoy the week how long
have we been doing two EPs a week it's
not been that long I guess it's a couple
months what's what for real a couple
months how old is Theodore because we
started doing it pretty much right after
he's just dead chronically underslept
well guys that's it you know find some
more news goofs gaffes
laughs current events and viral hits
talk about on Friday
[Music]
sorry guys see on Friday